ce qui définit la connaissance c'est son
ambivalence c'est ce qui fait que le
plus souvent quand on parle du mythe
prometheen c'est dans un sens péjoratif
c'est pour mettre en lumière la volonté
orgueilleuse de l'être humain de devenir
Dieu à la place de Dieu le mythe
prométhéin annonçant généralement la
ruine et la catastrophe la destruction
par lubrice
science en conscience n'est que ruine de
l'âme disait Rabelais connaissance sans
vertu mènera l'homme à sa perte le feu
ne serait ainsi pas seulement le symbole
de la connaissance il serait en même
temps le symbole de l'orgueil de
l'orgueil qui guide bien souvent notre
usage de la connaissance
le feu est-il peut-être en même temps la
flamme incandescente du désir du désir
qui nous brûle d'imposer notre règle
quitte à tout détruire
[Musique]